[Music]
do you feel vindicated
um i feel like a prophet
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
frances foster i'm constantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people i think it might be pretty
fascinating and honest today because we
have a returning guest it's kelly j
keane formerly known as posey parker who
holds the record for the most number of
views of any of our previous interviews
she's very happy about it kelly welcome
back thanks very much uh well i
mentioned our previous interview uh
you're obviously a women's rights
campaigner and the first time we had you
on we were talking about the trans issue
this would have been at least two years
ago uh and just to set the context for
everybody and you won't know this but i
do remember when you walked out
um
the interview is titled trans women
aren't women
when you walked out francis and i looked
at each other and went
okay
and then we sort of we had to put our
testicles back on to actually put the
interview out because at the time for
two comedians who who were still
operating in the comedy industry very
progressive uh we were recording it
above a comedy club where we were sort
of operating on the goodwill of the
people there
that was terrifying it was borderline
suicidal yeah that conversation was
absolutely terrifying and i think
i want to get your take on it but i
think that one of the reasons it has
done as well as it has is it's two jet
people who are genuinely trying to
investigate the issue they're possibly
putting forward arguments some of which
are well thought out and some less so
perhaps just pure pure ignorance
and someone is pushing back with facts
with arguments with logic without being
upset without getting angry there's a
bit of humor involved everybody has a
good time that sort of was the vibe of
it what was first of all your feeling
when you walked out of that conversation
um
i thought it was good i quite like the
opportunity to
answer an argument
and have a debate
it's quite
it's not as productive for anybody i
don't think if everyone goes oh yeah i
agree yeah i agree oh we all agree isn't
that great
and it's much more entertaining for
everybody else isn't it
but i think in order to
really present a good argument you
need somebody that doesn't necessarily
agree with you
and so i absolutely loved it yeah it was
great wasn't it and you know one of the
reasons that we wanted to get you back
now because we've covered the trans
issue we feel like to death and i think
most of our audience and us included now
kind of know where we stand on it and
that's partly let's be honest thanks to
you because you did open our eyes to a
lot of stuff
and one of the things that you were
saying at the time i'm not sure how
persuaded we were by at that time was
the slippery slope fallacy isn't always
a fallacy and if you allow certain
things to happen
well guess what two years later you
might have a party conference of a major
political party in this country
where you know ed david the leader of
the lib dems kierstarma the leader of
the labour party now essentially
they they don't today kirsten is saying
we need a james bond to be a woman but
two days earlier he couldn't even define
what a woman was
that's where we are so do you feel
vindicated
um i feel like a prophet
uh yeah i do and
i
i did know that if you can't name what a
woman is you can't really
say anything about us you can't defend
our rights uh you can't defend our
spaces a female space is no longer a
female space if there's a man in it
so
i knew this was coming
i kind of hoped it wasn't
but i think
the writings on the wall uh from
everybody i know
who's got anything to do with the labour
party and let's not forget that the
tories are in charge and they're not
doing very great things either the
liberal democrats are um
i mean if it wasn't such a serious issue
it's hilarious i mean they're just
proper
way out there
way out there and have we come to this
point how have we come to the point
where on a major political show
kierstarma when asked what a woman is
and do women have cervixes uh
essentially failed a year five biology
question
i i don't know then there must be such a
powerful minority in the labour party
that he just can't speak because it's
it's too ridiculous to think that
there's any rational
kind of lead up to that emily thornbury
she was asked the same question and she
said that her nephew is trans and he has
a cervix now i don't agree with her at
all i think that's a ridiculous thing to
say but at least there is you can
understand if you're
if you've got a knee i would say a niece
uh who identifies as transit and you
might not want to uh really offend her
so that's a little bit more
understandable but david
david lammy thinks that trans women men
have also have a cervix that when you
have srs
you and
you end up with a cervix i mean it's
like
all i can think when i see david lammy
is him saying there are no police here
with a police officer behind him
it feels like neighborhood policing has
vanished
it's not around you
we haven't seen the police while i've
been here and i've been here for a
little while now
it's he's that's just barmy
and it must be these very very powerful
activists but surely they can't have
that power or do you think they're just
worried about being cancelled smeared
etc etc well i think they must have
power i think power is the only thing
that could persuade
normal rational humans to say such
ridiculous things it can only be
power to force people to into newspeak
that's i don't
it's not rational is it there's no truth
it's not factual
so it it can only be sort of levers of
power well it's become a bit of a purity
test and and the first time we were
having that conversation i think the the
sort of tension that was in the air was
because we are two people who are
genuinely intellectually curious and try
to be honest
but also that pressure from the industry
we were operating within at that point
of time was coming into conflict and i
think a lot of people find themselves in
that position including in the labor
party why on the one hand you do want to
be honest and also you want to be
compassionate that was another thing
that was certainly motivating me and it
motivates me to this day i don't want to
upset people who do not have an easy
life they don't right for for the sake
of some kind of argument but at the same
time i think we're seeing now
that when people pretend to not know the
things that they know
it has consequences in every area
whether that's you know there's a new
transgender fighter in in in the mma
who's choking people out whether that's
laurel hubbard competing and taking the
places of women or whether that's the
transition is now coming through you're
seeing lots of young people who are
saying i was basically led down the
garden path and now i've chopped bits of
my body off
without necessarily being fully present
to what i was doing there's consequences
to this
there are massive consequences i sat in
the second day of the kiera bell
uh appeal when the tavistock said no but
we do want to give kids puberty blockers
uh which was a peculiar thing to sit
there thinking
me the taxpayer funding the tavistock to
insist upon
uh actually giving kids puberty blockers
and and one of their barristers was
talking about the autonomy of 10 year
olds and the agency of a 10 year old to
make that decision
sitting there and kiera bell's in front
and she's brought this whole case and
and even though she did lose
that particular bit of the the whole
ordeal for her
she's
open conversations globally so whatever
whatever happened in that courtroom she
totally won and it was incredible
but to listen to and i've watched the
three judges and one of them was like
the um
chief uh justice
uh there was another master of the robes
and there was another one
the female who i can't remember what her
role was
um but she was jolly good
she looked good and she said great yeah
um
and so the three of them and at no point
i was expecting at least a flicker of
something and an
enquiry into
really these are children how far is
this going to go and nobody was asking
those questions it was insane
so
um
in answer to your question i can't
remember what the question was well i i
think it was less of a question i i
actually
do want to ask you this because
we talk about the slippery slope not
necessarily being a fallacy we've seen
that with the trans issue we've seen
that with covered restrictions you know
people who were saying things a year ago
we're called conspiracy theorists now
those very thing things are happening
what do you think is coming
given what you're seeing because you
mentioned labour party lib dems but also
the tories not really doing very much on
this issue
where is this going
well the tories have got a a few people
i think who could really turn the tide
it just depends how much of a grip
carrie simmons has on
boris's um
yes
uh career
um
it's not a euphemism um so it just
depends how much of a grip the woke have
got on the conservatives
but where is it going well they've just
mandated this sort of consent for 12
year olds with vaccines so
i
i think it could go to some really
really dark places i think
there's so many little things that have
happened right to do with parents and
children and i'm a mother of four um
and the the little things like we're not
allowed to know
what they're doing in sex ed or you're
not allowed to take them out of um the
bullying lessons which often include
things that i don't necessarily would
you know i wouldn't have wanted my
seven-year-old to be talking about
um so there's severance there the
severance in in the relationship between
parents and children when it comes to
consent for vaccines
um in scotland
uh the nhs has sent
51 girls i think to
um
they called it something euphemistic but
uh basically having their breasts
removed under 18 51 girls so i
i don't know
is it an attack on reality is it a
severance of family are all the people
who've been saying that there's some
sort of crazy marxist takeover
uh happening are they a little bit right
yes
the the thing
that there's several things about this
issue that i find disturbing
particularly the use of language someone
very very very close to me is looking at
half for medical reasons having to go
through a double mastectomy
and reading up about it and we've sat
down together and you're looking at the
medical literature this is a very very
problematic invasive procedure
and they and then when you hear other
people talk about it these activists
they go oh it's just top surgery and you
think no it's not top surgery
this is a major in
medical procedure why are we using these
frivolous terms
well
there's loads of frivolous terms out
there sex worker for prostitution we get
away from the harrowing ordeal of being
like a
street prostitute if we call them sex
workers
and i think it's the same with top
surgery the other thing's called bottom
surgery um then there's
i don't really know what uh
there's getting breasts um
but yeah this
this need to disguise what's going on
like there's non-binary surgeries now so
a non-binary surgery might mean that you
have your
uh testicles inverted to create a cavity
but you would keep your penis um
girls who call themselves non-binary
because there is just an insane war on
breasts and i don't really know what
this is about
um but you'll have a scar from there to
there and you have your nipples removed
and you just and there's also
i think somebody called it mermaid
surgery where you have
quite a lot of things smoothed out like
your genitals smoothed out and you just
end up with a urethra so there's
there's it's it's so
gross that if you talk to somebody who
knows nothing about it
they will not believe a word you say
because it's so insane
and it it's insane and we seem to be
sacrificing our children that's the
thing that really blows my mind because
surely isn't it every parent's instinct
to protect their child
well you would think so right like if my
child had said to me when he was four
i'm a girl
the start and end of that conversation
would be are you
that would be it no drama no nothing
that would just
he'd forget about it i'd forget about it
i've read a woman who's
whose child wanted to wear
so basically he wanted a towel around
his hair after a shower like she did
and she said you can't have one and he
said i'm a girl
and so what she did with that she
thought about that all night long
and then within six months
that kid was transitioning and it's
women
uh
it's people with vaginas bodies
let's use the correct medical language
from the landsat it's bodies with
vaginas bodies with vaginas um that are
more likely to do that to their kids
now i've thought about this long and
hard i don't really know what that is
about because i find it that would go
against every instinctive fiber in my
body
to allow something like that to happen
to one of my children but it is
it is
women that are more likely to do it to
their kids
uh men are more likely to just bring
their autogynophilia into the family
home
which is uh the fetish of wanting to be
a woman
but no these um it's women it's women
doing it to their kids i've been saying
it for years
no
are you tired of using bulky old wallets
giving you a bulge where you don't want
it to be my old wallet was massive so it
brought all the ladies to the yard which
was a huge distraction and got in the
way of my esteemed work on trigonometry
ridge wallets have an incredible
solution for you this is mine sleek
stylish and with an industrial look to
it you can fit 12 cards with cash on the
back using a clip like this one or a
strap we've got one for the whole team
i've got one francis has one even our
producer anthony has one but he's from
liverpool so he flogged his on the black
market the great thing about ridge is
that they give you a lifetime guarantee
which means if you want you can have
only one wallet for the rest of your
life ridge are so confident in the
quality of their product they will give
you 45 days to test drive their wallets
that means you can get the wallet use it
and if you don't like it you can return
it within 45 days because ridge is such
great guys they're going to give you 10
off and free worldwide shipping and
returns to take advantage of this
incredible offer go to ridge.com forward
slash trigger that's ridge.com forward
slash trigger and use our special code
which is of course trigger
i do want to address the other side of
this conversation as we did last time
which is
not none of us here
people who want
anyone to be suffering or anyone to be
discriminated against or treated badly
and this is an area where
the rights of different groups come into
conflict
right that's why we're having this
conversation right
so and i appreciate that you're very
strongly on one side of that discussion
but how how do we not lose our humanity
in the process of this and not
dehumanize other people when we're
talking about it
well
uh because that is important would you
agree totally it's not look if if
somebody doesn't bring their
uh identity
or whatever into myspace if it doesn't
conflict with my rights
do i care
not very much
um
it's when that that person's
identity well it's not even it's such a
silly
word identity it's when that person's
wants and desires becomes something that
i have to deal with i don't want to deal
with it
i don't think it's any of my business
don't make it my business don't bring it
into my kids schools don't bring it into
my changing rooms my female only space
now the dehumanizing element um it
depends
how far we want to go i feel it's quite
dehumanizing to say that any man can be
a woman i think that totally devalues
and dehumanize what it is to be a woman
um
but i don't think people would say that
that was dehumanizing whereas if i say
that person is a man i should be able to
say that person is a man as a female i
understand that that person poses much
more of a threat to me than a female
now that can be from flashing
uh or just
looking at somebody now you lovely
gents
you prostate hovers
um
you probably haven't had those sort of
exchanges which most women have
since basically you get breasts um
and so the moment that you sort of turn
into a woman and sometimes even before
there's a lot of kind of uncomfortable
staring and that informs the way that
most women feel about men
and i i don't think that means that
every time i encounter a bloke i think
oh god he's he's a pervert he's a he's
probably a rapist i don't feel like that
at all
but i can definitely feel
creepy men yeah you know and i think
women feel it
women are vulnerable to men
in certain situations it's just a fact
right yeah
and go on
one of the things when people talk about
oh
the toilet issue not being an issue this
is the argument that someone presented
to me and i don't really think there's a
counter argument to it which is in a
nightclub situation
every woman has experience there's a
creepy guy who's following her around
who's making her feel uncomfortable
where's the number one play she heads to
in in the nightclub as a as as a method
of escape she goes to the female toilets
that is a safe space if that is
obliterated
she's got nowhere to go i know
it's um
i i
was lucky enough to go on holiday this
year and i just come back
and we went for a mcdonald's breakfast
because we are classy
and we went into the mcdonald's and i
was went to the loo
and i'm in the cubicle
and a man comes in
right
does not speak in english seems to be in
quite rush pushes open the door
i promise this is what i did i just went
and just didn't breathe
i didn't kind of at
my instant response it wasn't a rational
thing i just didn't breathe until he'd
left
because him in that space totally
changed that space now i wouldn't have
felt like that if it was a woman's voice
and so
for some reason we're gonna we're having
to pretend that that isn't how we feel
when we hear a man's voice
and it's not like i said it's you know
i've got i'm married to a lovely bloke
but
no matter how desperate he was for the
lou he's not going in the women's
toilets because he understands how women
feel about men in their space it's why
most men would cross over the road and
not walk behind a woman walking on her
own
and do you think most women feel like
that or do you think it's just the way a
certain section of women feel i think
most women feel like that there's a book
called by gavin de beca called the gift
of fear and it talks about your body
basically knows will respond to
something quicker than you will and
you'll feel it so that's like my my
holding my breath
now what i could have done which i think
now what a lot of women do is they would
rationalize it and start reasoning with
that instant response and they would
rationalize something that should
probably make them afraid and will
protect them
and i think that is happening
really scarily with this
younger generation of women
where they're not allowed to trust their
emotions at all and their instincts
they're being told that they're mean
they're unkind um and so i think i think
it's really quite dangerous i i don't
know a single woman that wouldn't feel
afraid in a public toilet for example if
a man came in
well that makes perfect sense so
come back to my compassion point though
okay yeah because i do want to explore
that because of all the questions that
i've now answered for myself that is one
i'm still struggling with
um
you don't strike me as a bigoted person
or as a nasty person at all but a lot of
people think you are though and i know
now why that is because
you'll refuse to bend
on things that matter right that's why
people consider you a nasty person
because you say it like it is on the
subject that most people are very
uncomfortable with right that that's why
so
but
but i think we all ought to and i think
we all try to actually
have compassion at the same time so how
do we
the language and the conversation seems
extremely polarized
is there any is there any way that this
conversation can be had in a more
healthy way or do you just feel like
it's a war and you have to win
uh
how can i put this because in a war
compassion is not a virtue it's advice
yeah right you have to you have to win
well i do i
i do feel i do have to win yeah um
because what is extinct what is at stake
is is
phenomenal and
uh just horrific
so for example the word woman
i was in a meeting the other day and
women who would call themselves
feminists like proper radical feminists
use the word
use the words
female people instead of woman
now i can only imagine the reason she
felt she had to use female people is
because the word woman would sound too
coarse too forthright too exclusionary
and so she didn't use it
now the reason we can't talk in terms
that you maybe feel it doesn't show any
compassion is because we've lost some of
the words that we should be able to use
for this now do i think a man that
can't go out or or just feels that
just feels that he needs to live as
something else whatever that might mean
to him
do i feel compassion for any human who
uh i think they're probably wrong that
that will end their suffering
but who am i
you know of course i feel compassion for
everybody but my compassion is so used
up
by
the women that
that will lose their rights lose the
ability to wait to be able to stay at
work
actually i don't really want
janet
using the toilets i felt really
uncomfortable or the woman that wants to
remove her hijab at lunchtime and wants
to go in the loo to do it and she can't
do it anymore because she can't
guarantee that's a female only space
or the teenage girl who goes in a
changing room in a toilet in a communal
changing room where there's communal
parts to a female changing room and
there's a guy who oh i don't know i
think we used to call it in decent
exposure who's bravely getting his
female penis uh out in the changing room
i'm it's my it's spent my compassion is
fully spent on
women and girls
so
i'm not inhuman
i do think that all human beings should
have equal access to equal rights
but not at my expense
and you say
not to your expense
what's going to be the end game do you
think if you don't
if you say that the war is lost if it is
a war
look where we are we've got rapists in
women's prisons let's look at america so
america is um so i sell merchandise um
and raise awareness and i've sold
merchandise to a quarter of the
countries in the known world
so i think it's quite a global issue
for women 25 of all my stuff goes to the
usa
uh
in america in california prisons there
are pregnant
women who have probably had pretty
awful lives in the prison population who
are impregnated by
other women
that are in the prison population
those women aren't allowed to know so
they sleep about eight in a room in
american prisons those women aren't
allowed to know that there's a man
coming into their
prison cell and
there's also men going in with hiv into
women's prisons and that person's human
rights to not let anybody know they've
got hiv
completely supersedes the women's rights
to know that somebody is coming in with
hiv
so we could be there we could be where
america is where they slice off the
breasts of like 13 year old girls
15 you can do it without your parents
consent in oregon
we could be like canada where they'll
take your kids away if you don't affirm
their
so-called gender
i think jordan peterson said about the
compassion thing
is it ultimately compassionate to lie
and i don't think it is i think a really
brave kind thing and
you know like i say i've got kids the
kindest thing i do for my kids is not
necessarily give them what they want
and i still love them and adore them but
you know if if my son wanted to get up
every day and have like a 200 gram bar
of chocolate
for his breakfast i'm not gonna allow
him to do that and that would be a an
act of
kindness and compassion
where i found this ideology starting to
encroach more and more not into our
lives because
i think we can all agree that we all
live pretty
weird lives when we consider what we do
but when i talk to my friends who've got
regular jobs and all of a sudden now
they've had to tell people what their
pronouns are
and how they want to be addressed and
you see that in very very liberal media
circles like in the theater we're at the
start of the rehearsal everybody has to
announce their pronouns
but it's also coming into the corporate
world
i can tell that you're not going to
agree with this why do you disagree with
the whole pronoun thing and having to
announce it
i think it's quite weird
i think
i mean what do people want like clearly
i this is what i went to a feminist
meeting a long time ago and
and i did a my first like facebook live
um
and they sort of wanted pronouns now i
look like i look like this
i'm five foot one i'm quite clearly
a woman
if you don't know what my pronouns might
be then you're a bit of an idiot
um and i just think it's asking of
people it's asking people to
uh it's very sneaky it's saying
come into this ideology
nobody really needs to know i mean if
we're all supposed to be equal like if
we were in a truly progressive place
then would it really matter what
anybody's pronouns are or how anybody
identifies at work
i mean does it mean that you can't do
john's accounts on a friday if you're
are they them
uh
i mean it's just
i
no
i've got friends who work in places
where they have to wear the rainbow
lanyard and they hate it
they don't want to they want to just go
to work
you know not many not many of them
absolutely adore their jobs they do it
because they want to actually have a
life and pay for their mortgage you know
there's not too many people skipping to
work and
going damn five o'clock on a friday um i
wish i could just work the whole weekend
uh these are our places of work they're
not places to encourage us to be
ideologically um insane do you think
this is this is really where we are and
it applies to much more than just the
trans issue which is
we've just for some reason i don't
really understand why i've decided that
the point of all aspects of society is
to do social engineering the police is
not about policing crime it's about
social engineering civil service is not
about running the country it's about
social engineering comedy is not about
making jokes it's about social
engineering
every aspect of our society now wherever
you look it seems to be that social
engineering is the number one priority
and the actual function of that
organization seems to be secondary at
the very least
if i believed in massive conspiracy
theories and i was in china
right
i'd love this right now wouldn't you you
just place all these little things like
oh let's not help them think about like
long-term financial solutions that are
going to make the poorest in the country
more wealthy um let's not do that let's
make them all talk about gender let's
make them all talk about racism
let's do that i i just
if they if they found a troll farm
that was more deadly than covid
uh i wouldn't be surprised i just think
that
kind of was the only thing that really
does make sense that the the information
war is upon us
and loads of these things they're not
real issues are they no a real issue is
not being able to buy a house in your
like mid 20s or 30s
uh i just talked to a lovely taxi driver
my parents were both manual workers they
got married as teenagers
within three years of being married and
they had two children by then living
with my grandmother they could afford a
house
and like my dad literally sorted
sheepskins in a i mean they both did
very well they both worked really hard
and my mother was a with cleaned offices
because she had small children they
could buy a house
when i was a little girl teachers were
well off
they were the people in the nice houses
and the brand new estates they had big
houses
now
i think that's maybe that's the the
whole replacement thing that if you
think about these kind of ethereal
ideological things you're not really
thinking about actually my life's pretty
bad
i've got no control
i'm never going to be able to afford to
buy a house i'm never going to be able
to leave this job my rent is so high
which means i can't save for a deposit
all of those things are really really
important they make a difference workers
rights so in this country
we've got the equality act and i was
looking into it to see whether or not we
should just totally get rid of it and
start again and have separate like a
disability rights act for example um
because i think that really
that really is important
just to go on a tangent
trains may be emblazoned with pride
flags
but most people in with disabilities
have to plan a journey
like months in advance to make sure that
there's someone to meet them and half
the stations don't even have you can't
even get off a train onto a platform
nobody cares about that it's much better
to talk about
the minority rights of lgbt people which
i have no idea what rights those people
don't have in this country
um
and now i've forgotten where i've gone
with my tangent well actually it was a
you were making i think what is a very
profound point which is
all of these distractions
and the conversations we have about all
of these issues which are much more
intellectual than practical are a way of
giving us all something to chew on
mentally and to try and control
in a world in which we increasingly
control less and less have less and less
particularly for young people
opportunities that they see in front of
them going forward so if you can't
control your job you can't control your
housing you can't control your prospect
but you can control your gender and by
the way if you start talking about it
quite a lot you're going to get
attention you're going to get positive
reinforcement if you do it on social
media you might become a mini celebrity
in that world etc um and it's all a
distraction so should we stop talking
about it
well we could but the unfortunate thing
is it now has practical consequences
and so i think it did start off as
there's something uh like a few people
talking about it online
and it blew up and then the the shame of
it all
the thing that killed it is when the
state got involved so in 2004 when we
made a legal fiction which was basically
to cover up the fact that we were
homophobes and we didn't want gay people
to marry same-sex couples to marry then
we invented this gra and this gender
recognition act and the lovely david
lammy was instrumental and norman
tebbett
said are we really creating a an act in
which women will be um
have x y chromosomes and men will have
xx this is a fiction this is not true um
and anne whitaker i think she also spoke
against it
uh conviction politicians what happened
to them
um
and so
it's just
it's that's the bit that that's ruined
it
because you can have fringe people that
kind of think that
gender is something ethereal and we can
just do whatever we like and isn't that
great and yeah you know
people have always had crazy ideas we
just didn't have a state that stepped in
and gone oh yeah that's right let's
teach it in schools
i think the one
part of
your argument that people would really
push back on is the autogynophile
element of it and you've used that word
once number one
what does that actually mean
okay so it's the fetish of embodying
of having a vagina and embodying the
body of a woman so it's about literally
wanting to be a woman or believing that
you are so you you have a sexual fantasy
and you're turned on by yourself as a
woman
mm-hmm
right you look a bit sick
or excited depends i mean there's new
frontiers every day posey so that being
the case right
to what extent do you personally think
that
people identifying or as a woman have
this condition and why do you think that
so i
think it's probably a really large
number so we used to call people we used
to call them transsexuals and
transvestites
and i think we knew that transvestites
uh
had a fetish and
they didn't often walk around the
streets in their get up they often sort
of kept it at home you know like where
i don't know arguably that's where you
should
perform your kink
um so
we knew that this happened we knew that
there were issues with it but
these men used to meet in secret and
it's all a bit shameful and taboo which
is also part of the excitement of being
an autogynophile and
grace and perry will talk about it
risk is a big aphrodisiac
you know and i mean the first time i
went out in my mum's
clothes was very very exciting and i
became addicted to that
he'll talk about absolutely
that sexual arousal is all part of his
dress up that's why he wears quite wide
dresses
and he'll talk about that that's not me
saying that that's what he does
and but now we have to pretend that
that's not right and it's stunning and
brave
i think about 10 of all porn consumed is
i can't use they would use the word to
describe it so transsexual or
men who have male genitals but also have
breast implants
that's quite high in porn uh i talked to
a mother
and her son had been booted out of um a
baseball team
and
she said
that he then sort of went in his room
for a couple of years he was absolutely
gutted because it was american and
obviously in america these things are
massive aren't they if you're part of
like a the first team and unlike in
britain where i think if you're not in
the first scene there's a second to a
third if you're not in the team you're
out and he was really depressed and then
she said he said that he was a woman he
identifies as a girl
and it transpired that he identified as
a girl because he really enjoyed
watching pornography featuring lesbians
and so he decided he wanted to be a
lesbian
and so that would be the beginnings of
what we would call autogynophilia
um
there's all sorts of reasons that people
have uh sexual fetishes there are men
that are obsessed with feet
uh i know one such man that's obsessed
with feet and that's because
his mother mainly ignored him but her
friend used to kick him under the table
you know these i think your sexual
fetish kind of the mechanics of it can
set before you're
sort of six seven years old again grace
and perry will talk about this this is
not something that i've made up
um so i do think there's a high rate of
auto gun affiliate debbie hayton for
example that you had on has written
about being an autogynophile
and that being the case so where does
gender dysphoria come into it then
for them
i don't know
i don't know that it does
i think if you had a powerful like i
women don't really have fetishes as much
as men i'm not saying none of us do
but
generally speaking we don't we also
don't have the same relationship with
sex as men do uh many women have tried
to pretend that we're the same as men
but we're really really not our bodies
are very very different
um
but
the
driver of um
sexual fetish
and the power i think it can have over
someone
uh if you look at murder for example
that can sometimes be a sexual fetish
and so that will go from
as shown in sarah everard's murder
flashing
and it would just go up
and it would just increase and it's all
to do with a sexual driver often serial
killers are driven by sexual desires
um
and we know this we know this we know
that there
there used to be um all sorts of
different inquiries into behavior
studies as to why people commit these
crimes
we don't seem to want to look at that
anymore
i'm going to be honest with you when we
started the show three and a half years
ago i didn't think we'd be sitting
talking about uh what's up kind of
sorry no it's not your fault i'm just
i'm like how do we get here
this is so weird
why like if i try and explain this stuff
to like my family back
i like my mom i i'm not even sure i can
explain to my mom what i do for a living
anymore
we're like we are through the looking
glass with this [ __ ] i know
and i find it very confusing um honestly
there's kink clubs at universities
official
kink club bdsm
official university is it discord
so
yeah yeah so um bdsm
my son was sent out um on instagram
there was a post about sex work
being a sex worker as a student
what yeah
so so i just want this clarified because
i'm suddenly feeling very old and very
conservative
sex workers in prostitution or being a
stripper or no i said
anything goes anything
how to be safe and a sex worker
at uni had to pay your way through uni
being a sex worker
do you think the pendulum is just
overswung here
kelly that you know
we the society was discriminatory
against gay people it was discriminatory
against women and in the process of
liberating all those groups and making
sure they all had the same rights as
everybody else we kind of just went you
know what let's let's not have shame
about anything let's say that everything
is normal everything every human
instinct
is to be celebrated
there's nothing wrong with anything
there's no right or wrong that's
moralistic judgments and we need to
everything is relative and it's all
about you know whatever
and we've just gone a little bit too far
and therefore we're going to have a
correction back when the pendulum sort
of slows and stops and then swings back
what i fear
is that we'll go so far into chaos
that the only thing that will be able to
bring us back is a very prescriptive
religion yeah
so i i do fear that
it's like humans at the moment are all
running around nobody knows what's
morally okay
um in the 1980s single mothers were
demonized terrible they're the sort of
people that were left behind raising
children
um
and that was they were supposed to feel
a great deal of shame
and now you've got women in pajamas
walking their kids to school eating a
packet of frazzles for breakfast
with no shame whatsoever and if you
criticize those women if you say
jesus like
how is that kid gonna have any sort of
life or whatever you're like oh well you
know that's really shameful and shaming
um but i bring it back i say bring back
bring back shame well this is
i mean
i said this the other day like the
culture was basically turning a lot of
normal people into these
radical reactionaries simply because
quite a lot of us are just going
you've gone too far now
you know
like some things ought not to be
encouraged
do you know and i mean you gave an
example there but you know single
parenthood whether it's mothers or
fathers to say that it's not going to
lead to the best outcome statistically
speaking now you're you're shaming
whatever slut-shaming well is it a good
idea for for
women to have sex with hundreds of men
and to treat sex the way men do who are
designed biologically very differently
is it or should should i mean every
society prior to us has had some sort of
restrictions around that to encourage
certain types is do we do do we throw
all
past
learning out of the window
i reckon
apparently that's where we're going i
think religion left
and the big gaping void that it's left
is being filled with narcissistic
desires
i think that's and i'm an atheist i'm a
gold star atheist i've never believed in
god at all
but i do think i'm very lucky to have
been born in a country where
the themes of uh christian moral
thinking were still running through
our education system whereas now it's
really weird on the left isn't it
because
they'll really go for christians but not
other religions which i would argue were
maybe much more problematic than
christianity much more prescriptive much
more sexist
um and it's just it's really interesting
i made a comment she's talking about
mormonism
well i made a comment the other night
about um
i think i might have even been talking
about afghanistan and someone said
something about they were american they
said something about
their country was really bad on a on
abortion as if it was comparable i was
like well
find me a christian government that is
um controlling a country and stopping
women from being able to have jobs and
i'm going to agree with you 100
but
america well it's a republic but it's
like a democratic republic and they've
decided in some places i totally don't
agree
but they've decided in some places that
they don't want people to have access to
abortion or past a certain point
i don't think that is barbarism i think
they're totally wrong and i think they
need to win the argument properly
um in those places
but that is what democracy is about it's
not always about doing the things that
are right or that you totally agree with
it's about
the will of the people
to me
a large part of the problem comes from
feminism itself
anton get the smelling salts
go on we have we tried to have this
conversation last time if you remember
yeah because
she she called me an mri yeah pretty
much i was that was my jokes
but you look at a lot of what feminism
should be standing up for is standing up
for women
and they don't seem to be like you see
what's happening in afghanistan
where are the feminists up in arms about
the treatment of women
where are they commenting you know they
you know they will absolutely lambast
and i don't know enough about the issue
about the
about what's happening in america
but they they won't criticize islam no i
know and you go well hang on a second
what is it only white women that you
care about or western women
oh no there's cultural relativism so if
it's happening in in another culture
then you can't comment so if somebody's
getting their genitals completely sliced
off in another country you shouldn't
really talk about that
somebody i had a discussion with
somebody of the day online
and um
she totally lost the argument but it was
very funny
so i was sort of trying to say look i
know you don't agree with me i really
respect the fact that you'll talk
because i'm trying to understand why
anybody would think it's all right for a
child age four
to call themselves the opposite sex like
where you think that goes what do you
think the harms are
and she said well you know different
people make different life choices
in some countries there's child marriage
but
in some countries there's child marriage
but you know culturally that's not okay
here and i was like if you just said
it's all right that there's child
marriage
and she said well i'm just saying people
make different choices when what child
has made that that choice i was like
look you've lost the argument let's just
move past that because i still want to
understand but yeah there are
there are people that talk in those
terms so
do p do feminist care
well it depends what sort of feminists
but do feminists care about afghanistan
there have been some radical feminists
about 30 of them who rescued quite a lot
of women
um
and so i i do think they care
um it's a bit like qatar
with a football they're gonna take the
knee for all the slaves that died
building the
uh stadium will they take the knee there
or is it only historical
slavery that we need to care about it's
it's it's all this nonsense
like there's there's people fishing for
prawns in thailand where what they do is
they take a load of people and they
chuck one person off
right at the beginning of their trip so
everybody just does exactly as they're
told
you know there's modern slavery that
totally dwarfs historical slavery but we
don't nobody's talking about that
it's so
let's go back to
the origins of feminism
do i think feminism has a part to play
yes i probably do
um
i think there is something in the notion
even with second wave that said men and
women are the same it's just the way
we're socialized
so i inhabit this body
it's female it's five foot one i'd
probably be a different person if i was
five for eight
i'd probably be a different person if i
had totally different facial features
you know but i think it's a mistake
to try and say that nothing is to do
with our biology which then would lead
you to the female brain
um
but also i i have this feeling about
instinct and it comes back to the fact
that
i think i'm informed not just by my own
experiences but by the experience and
legacy of people that have come before
me and not in some weird kind of
sense not in that past life kind of
proper memory but in the way that humans
know
to clench their fists
um when they're tiny babies you know if
you do that to a baby they'll clench
their fist these little puppies i've got
at home at the moment
they basically swim around
and they know how to root to make sure
that they can feed and so to say that
we're not born with other legacy of
behaviors that may be directly
correlated with our sex
i don't think that's like the most
preposterous idea i've ever had no i
don't think it is
and and i don't want to be in this place
i don't want to be this person going
yeah we need to go or whatever but
but here's another question which is
difficult for i think for feminism and
you're not part of that movement but
what about gender stereotypes right
because
how much of that is biological right how
much of that ought to be encouraged to
facilitate a normal quote-unquote woman
or a normal quote-unquote man
functioning in society because
if you encourage men to behave and to
behave in ways that are suitable for men
in the society that you exist you're
making their life easier right if you
encourage women to behave in ways
that
help them navigate the society that we
live in well you are indoctrinating them
with certain ideas about right and wrong
and how do you behave and what you wear
sometimes and all of that stuff
do we throw all of that out of the
window or do we need a bit of that
that's the question isn't it well i'm a
heterosexual woman so i quite like to be
well i don't know if i'd do that anymore
but i quite like to be attracted to the
opposite sex
and to say
there's loads of modern things that
people say is a proof that they're men
and women and it's biological but loads
of the things that they would use to
prove that
then they can't be biological because
years and years ago those things didn't
exist
but
do i think my husband and i are
fundamentally different yes my
hypothalamus when i was pregnant with
babies and then had a baby
if my baby woke up in the middle of the
night i woke up before my baby before i
could hear my baby i was awake because
i'm somehow connected because i don't
know i'm a mammal
they're supposed to keep their baby
alive and my husband's role he always
felt was not just to care for our
children but to make sure i was all
right so i could care for our children
which makes me a trad wife
um
in short supply and in high demand i
know it's so weird um
but he also is in it we are in a very
fortuitous position that i could stay
home and look after my children which is
not something that many women can do and
i would like to see more women have a
genuine choice to do that if they wish i
don't see the reason that we should send
a woman back to tesco's to stack shelves
to
pay somebody else crappy wages to look
after her child while she earns crappy
wages i think the government should pay
women to stay at home or tax break
somehow something i certainly don't want
the state any more involved than it is
um
what i'm getting at is
if we're talking about sort of like the
pendulum not swinging too far
i wonder whether an element of gender
stereotype teaching children well you're
a boy this is what you do you're a girl
this is how you behave right
i mean is that entirely not
wrong and evil and useless i mean give
you an example right boys don't cry
right and we we now talk about how all
men are all they've got all these
feelings that they're not like i don't
know that it's good for men to be
letting out all their feelings i don't
know that society responds to men
letting out all their feelings in in a
way
that makes it a good idea for men to do
that i don't know that men's biology is
necessarily geared towards that way of
releasing emotion men do different
things to deal with and process emotion
so
the idea that you talked about this were
all the same i don't know that we're all
the same even on that level even on the
level of cultural teaching of how you
behave and how you behave
is is is that you know because as you
say there was a point where feminism was
advocating well that's all just
wrong and bad and we just need to
everyone's a blank slate are we
oh god i don't know i like to think that
my kids were allowed to
play with whatever they wanted
my daughter's probably the least likely
to have cried up to the age of about
seven well even now and i don't cry very
much either i don't imagine you do
i'm a little bit i do angry um
but i just don't cry very much and and
i i don't know if anybody should be
crying a lot to be honest
uh
but i do think that the lightened shade
of male and female
i think it complements
yeah you know my husband couldn't fall
apart when i just had a baby i probably
had to fall apart a little bit
when i just had a baby because i was
very very very tired
um and so he needed to be strong there
have been times when he's had like a
couple of issues or whatever but
[Music]
it wouldn't be particularly attractive
would it if he sat at the kitchen team
crying everybody having a breakdown it
just that that's my point and i
i'm not supposed to have said that
obviously i hate being the guy who's
like actually things were
i don't want to be in this position but
on the other hand like i said the
entirety of the culture war can be
summed up by that meme where you've got
uh like a normal person and one of these
like pink-haired weirdos and the
pink-haired weirdo says to the normal
person who radicalized you and the
normal person says you
right to me that is the entire point
there's the entire core of the culture
war it's normal people having the ship
pushed on them that doesn't make any
sense it doesn't work it's not connected
to reality it's impractical and it's
hurting people the backlash is not going
to be nice and that's my worry
when do you think that's going to happen
and what is it going to look like
well i think we saw a little bit in the
football stadium didn't we when they
started
like no we're not going to have you
kneeling like we're not racist we've
we've solved that
like
you know
so
i mean maybe there still is racism in
football i don't go to football matches
i don't know but i can't imagine that
too many people have much tolerance for
racial racial abuse
in the stands so i think it's coming i
think people are really beginning to
have enough
but i think it's going to get so much
worse before that backlash comes
um
and i think people will start joining
people will start all the things that
we're supposed to fear we're supposed to
think the biggest threat in this country
is the far right
i mean i've yet to really see them for
these remarkably visible powerful men
um that are patrolling our streets i
don't think they that is the biggest
threat to this country i think the
biggest threat is is lies and dishonesty
and a lack of reality or a lack of like
people basically are throwing water in
your face and going
you're completely dry what are you
talking about
like wiping
water do you think that this is going to
be the issue that breaks the whole
culture war
well the trans stuff
possibly because it is
just in your face untrue like
as a as a white person
um
i probably
can't speak
to
uh what levels of racism really happen
on a daily basis
because it's very likely that i'm not
going to see them and i'm not going to
hear them so somebody could have two
points of view
and they could both be telling exactly
what is happening in their lives and
they could be polar opposites but both
would be true yeah
men can be women women could be men
that's it's either true or it's not true
there are no points of there's no two
points of view on that where both people
are telling the truth
and i think that's the fundamental
difference between almost any of the
other cancelling culture
war stuff going on and where do you
stand on this whole idea that sex and
gender are separate that sex is one
thing and gender is another altogether
well i think gender is a big fat mistake
to even bring it into the world even
to give birth to that word is
it just is the beginning of such a load
of nonsense
so
i think there is biological sex and i
think there are stereotypes and i think
there are sex roles and i think there
are lots of things associated with me
being female
and you guys being male
um
the idea that gender exists somewhere
that isn't dependent on those things
is a stupid stupid argument made up by
feminists
by some people
in
universities um but yeah feminist theory
that sort of started talking about that
so you could you could
you could basically take
a person's
i don't know what is it i mean it's kind
of religious isn't it
it's um
so one of my kids was saying the other
day sorry i'm just going
one of my kids said the other day about
um
somebody who identified and i said well
you either have to believe two things
you either have to believe that gender
is some unquantifiable
uh metaphysical non-existent can't touch
it
thing that exists in every human like
our soul
or you have to believe that the code of
dna did every single bit right that did
my female body right and then when it
got to my brain it went oh
i think i'm just gonna put a male one
here and then builds the rest of my body
around it
those two things are the only thing that
make gender a remotely possible thing
and i think both are nonsense
and that's going to trigger a few people
i it's such a weird place that we're in
i don't really know what to say i just
find it all incredibly weird
and and
i i see these discussions and mumsnet
love to talk about us and us having
these conversations and they get this
and they don't get this and are they
allies
i don't care i care about the truth i
care about the truth right and the truth
is just because you uttered an
incantation
that does not change who you are
biologically it [ __ ] doesn't
it doesn't right and doesn't make me an
ally or an enemy or anything and it
doesn't mean that i don't care about
people and i'm not compassionate towards
them and i don't want them to be
included in as much as they can be
i just don't want to lie
i don't want to lie
and i think a lot of people are starting
to feel that way that increasingly
living in society now requires you to
lie
on a daily basis yeah and to accept
things that you
shouldn't have to accept
you know
um
it's very frustrating because i i really
don't want to be in this position
no i i i like to think of myself as this
hey everybody do what you want i'm
liberal you know in the in the actual
meaning of the word liberal right well
apparently i'm not anymore you know i'm
a bigot just like you well i think you
probably are uh liberal i think they're
the bigots aren't they to insist to
enforce an ideology on somebody is is
pretty crappy
i mean it like the euphemism goes even
through to
uh what is another now we've got the
rise of surrogacy as if that's a gay
human right
uh and gay men in surrogacy circles are
just called infertile because two men
can't have a baby together so they're
now called infertile
no
they're just they're just men
and so surrogacy is massively on the
uprise and the changing of language in
those laws is frightening as hell where
they
even in the trans thing they call people
young people they don't call them
children
and so just that little switcheroo
you're a teacher we're a teacher
but just even that little switch of
talking about young people instead of
children i think totally changes
the way we can talk about
young people
children agency you can't say child has
agency and autonomy to make these
decisions and soon as you say something
like a child can consent you're just
really on a quick direct line to
any of the famous pedophiles we could
think about right
absolutely
absolutely it's like if children can
consent to taking a vaccine against
their parents wishes if they consent to
taking puberty blockers
what else are they going to be able to
consent to very soon
all right look we haven't had enough
conflict in this one the last thing
yeah no
uh the one i'm a feminist
the one question the worst yeah
i was gonna say he's gonna grab you
after this don't do that no no
absolutely not uh i'm not left-wing
right okay so here's the thing
what does that say about that
what does that say what does this
conversation say about as a society as a
whole
god
i think it says that we are divorcing
really quickly from reality
really quickly
and i think it's quite dangerous all the
tangible places you could have a nice
foothold
they're disappearing so biological sex
uh what parentage might be
um
you know there's
it's all this surface level wants and
desires have replaced
rights
and
concrete things that we need to sustain
uh
you know most people spend a lot of
their time on their phones not talking
to people in real life i think the
pandemic probably exacerbated that
somewhat
um
you know i've hardly heard anybody talk
about
how horrific it must have been for
elderly people i mean it's bad enough
for anybody being on their own but for
some people they might have spent 18
months of their last two years on earth
barely seeing anybody or having a
conversation on a daily basis now i
think that is something that was is
worth talking about uh rather than
someone's identity so i just
i don't know we need to get back to
real
tangible
consequence-led
sort of society when you where you can
genuinely affect change in your own life
i think we've got to a point where in
order to be someone
you just have to say something whereas
it used to be that you'd had to do
something you'd have to really do
something to be someone that's what
people wanted to do they you know even
if it was to be the best plumber that
anybody had ever uh come across or write
a novel or climb a mountain or whatever
it is but now you just have to come out
oh i'm genderqueer what does that mean
it means once i had a blue fringe
that's that's the be all and end all of
my identity that's all i've ever done
aren't you stunning and brave oh god
you're amazing
and on that note persie thank you so
much for coming on the show the one
question we always finish before we do
our questions for locals is what's the
one thing we're not talking about but we
really should be
well i think in the light of the sarah
everard
murder
i think we really do need to talk about
uh
what police serving police officers
actually get away with and why something
like indecent exposure which um
i'm not even gonna say his name which
the murdering rapist evil crap man
um
he committed in 2015 and how he managed
to keep his job
so i think we need to look at
low-level
what's called low-level sexual assault
and how we used to know that that leads
can lead can be the first step
in some really serious crimes
it's a very important point
kelly jacob thank you so much for coming
back we're going to do a couple of
questions for locals before we do where
are you not yet banned from online that
people can find so many places um i
can't even change i can't even sign a
change.org uh petition i'm banned from
that
um
you can find my youtube channel kelly j
keane uh you can find me at standing for
women and all of our lovely merchandise
is on adult human female.store
thanks for coming back and thank you for
watching and listening at home we'll see
you very soon with another brilliant
interview like this one or raw show all
of them go out 7pm uk time plus if
you're on the move and you want your
trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals community using the
link below